Oh what's happening you have been
selected maybe in body Steve Irwin get
something going in this Berwyn just
mimic me I won't be possible
nope nope nope damn really good it do so
bad can I practice by myself and come
back I just like I'm just gonna wheel
over here he needs some time alone here
goes
hi everybody this it's really hard the
Australian accent only Australia yeah
shrimp on the barbie
good day mate good day mate you're
supposed to make it sound like good aye
mate good I might good I might my name
is Caitlin my name is Mike I'm from
Sydney Australia it's going surfing I'm
terrible at this accent so in Mad Max
they they talk like this you don't mind
if I borrow your car for a weekend
there's a British woman who works here
and I can hear that it's messing up my
Australian so I have to like don't blame
her
I wish all Australians were like Tania
you guys I know so we're you guys put
other vowels in there such as the oh no
no just they no no no I went to the
shops the other day and bought some beer
okay I went to the shops and bought some
beer I went to the shops the other day
and bought some beers decided pretty
much exactly the same I went to the
shops and bought some beer I went to the
shops and brought some beer I went to
the shops the other day and bought some
bear I went to the shops and put some
bear what'd I do wrong everything I went
to the shops the other day and bought
some beer
pretty good pretty English pretty good
Australian accent in English accent not
think they're not that different right
whoa
I went to the shops and bought some
beers that was the closest we've come
I'd say yeah oh you did say no no see
that no
nose nose is like a NY OS nose I've had
enough of this discrimination
gabbi's all around